good afternoon everyone we're gonna get
started in about three or four minutes
thank you
[Music]
let's hear
what
you guys ready what
okay I think I think we're gonna get go
ahead and get started with the next
panel here since it's one sit closer to
the microphone okay now we're gonna get
started with the next panel so hi
everybody my name is Matt maroon I'm the
CEO and co-founder of watt learn why
learn is a startup company based here in
Pittsburgh where we're building an
artificial intelligence software
platform to better manage battery
systems so basically we're using machine
learning to give batteries of brain help
them maximize both the value and life of
those systems on the grid but today
we're gonna talk about next generation
in energy storage systems so I think
everyone recognizes over the past 10
years or so batteries have been been a
ubiquitous part of our life so from
batteries that we now carry everywhere
with us to electric vehicles to the
batteries that are being installed on
the grid to manage intermittency of
renewables provide backup power and all
sorts of other grid services so what
we're gonna talk about here with the
panel that's I would say much smarter
than me are what's happening in research
so everything from advanced materials to
how we measure and collect and analyze
data how is all of that giving better
information to make better systems to
make better battery technologies so just
moving down to introductions so I don't
don't think I need to introduce Jay
who's the moderator of today's session
next to Jay is a Ted Wiley so Ted is the
co-founder and CEO of forum energy
Ted began his career with the US Army is
an infantry officer and then went on to
become co-founder and head of product at
aqua energy before moving to form he was
president of McDonough innovation and
form is a start-up focused on
long-duration energy storage to really
enable widespread adoption of renewables
so moving closer and closer to base load
next to Ted Venkat Viswanathan he is he
assists
professor of mechanical chemical
engineering and material science here at
Carnegie Mellon his research group has
led has broad expertise in energy
storage and lithium-ion specifically as
they pertain to electric vehicles and
planes his focus is on identifying the
scientific principles governing material
design in organic organic and
biomaterials for novel in Turkey energy
conversion and storage routes next James
Fleetwood who's the research director
for the battery Innovation Center in
south-central Indiana he works with the
cell manufacturing team at the battery
Innovation Center which fabricates novel
electrode materials optimizes
performance parameters with the focus on
prototype performance evaluation and
scale-up to commercialization
and lastly Eli Leland the co-founder and
chief product officer of voltaic Eli
serves as the company's chief product
officer in guides the voltaic product
roadmap as well as post sale customer
experience Eli and his co-founder tall
started voltaic in 2012 in order to
address data analysis workflow
challenges that they personally
encountered while running RPE energy
storage Research Projects at SUNY Energy
Institute in New York City thank you so
much Matt and it could quickly thank our
distinguished panel for coming
[Applause]
and I've asked Matt to sit up here as
well mainly because he's so handsome we
need some of that help Ted also told me
to start with the joke
so so I'm gonna ask each panelist first
the same question and they're gonna
answer from their own context what they
think about it and we have a couple of
those and some individual questions then
we'll open it up to the floor so please
do use the app and the instructions are
on the table to use that so I guess I'll
start with Ted and the first question is
about sort of what happened what's
happened in the past ten years and I was
thinking last night it was nine about
nine years ago you and I were on the
fourth floor of Wayne Hall in my
cinderblock office writing a five
million dollar proposal to the do e to
get a RRA money which we won and we just
made some real tall promises and we
delivered on those and then it's sort of
a chaos ensued but and and so you start
off but I'd love to hear everyone else's
opinion what has happened in your world
in the past ten years of energy storage
just to frame the context as we talk
about next generation research
yeah that's great ten years ago I was in
Business School and a really amazing
kind of important thing happened to me
there was this field study class called
building green businesses and each the
groups of two or three students got to
select a project and work with somebody
out in the outside world on something in
the green clean tech space and me and
two others selected a project called
stealth battery company which was backed
by kleiner perkins and that was Jay and
what happened was kleiner had provided
some research money to Jay to start
evaluating new alternatives to ultra
low-cost energy storage so over the
subsequent six months we did a field
study project for Jay at the end of
which I was looking for a job because I
was graduating from my MBA and the
kleiner partner suggested I come out and
meet Jay and see if it might be
interesting to help him spin the company
out of his lab at Carnegie Mellon I came
out here in May of 2009 and who we
immediately got along we had a shared
worldview a shared passion for
sustainability and clean energy and we
said yeah let's do this so I moved to
Pittsburgh full-time and I lived there
for the next six years I met my wife at
that time lithium-ion batteries were
about twelve hundred dollars a kilowatt
hour you know Dave mentioned a
precipitous decline from you know a
thousand dollars a kilowatt hour in 2010
to you know maybe in the in the hundreds
to a hundred now for the battery pack we
Jay and I started aqueon energy which
was an alternative to lithium-ion for
stationary energy storage
we built a manufacturing our team built
a manufacturing facility Matt was on our
team as are some others that are in the
audience today and we we sort of went
through what I might call battery 1.0
which was developing technologies and
trying to find an application in the
market to use them for and thinking
about also how do you make the market
for energy storage so how do you develop
the technology how do you find a useful
application and how do you convince
people to buy so we were we were
creating a market as an industry at the
same time we were creating technologies
and you know at that time the biggest
batteries that were being deployed were
you know megawatt batteries 1 megawatt
for 15 minutes for instance and you know
today hundreds too soon thousands of
megawatt hours of batteries are being
deployed yearly around the world so the
you know this has gone from an
experimental idea that was really at the
fringe of the global electricity
industry to something that people
consider to be one of the big solutions
going forward for the grid and it's been
incredible to watch and be a part of
yeah so 10 years ago roughly I started
graduate school and I came to Stanford
and I think one useful thing that
happened was I did my undergrad at IIT
which is a place of perfect competition
and so one amazing thing that happened
was most of my friends close friends
ended up on the East Coast and so I was
sort of the loner there on the west
coast and that fundamentally changed my
thinking at least in terms of decoupling
difficulty of problem and importance of
problem and I think that sort of is my
journey into becoming an accidental
electric chemist so I started my
graduate school and wanted to work on
fluid mechanics which is if you're if
you did mechanical engineering as an
undergrad that's probably one of the
topics that you would think is hard
I came in to graduate school in the
division of computational fluid dynamics
quickly realized there are not many
important things to be done in that
field and then the second accident that
happened was I did a summer internship
at Bosch and they defined a problem in
batteries and I done nothing in
batteries up until that point this is
just a message to many of you that may
be thinking about getting into batteries
and I have no background I had no
background eight years ago and I'm here
so so I think that you know everyone can
get there by spending the right amount
of time on it so I I switched sort of
midway through my PhD to think on
lithium ion and and next generation
chemistry is related to lithium air and
and I I i interviewed here actually as a
graduate student J was J was in the
audience and and he asked the sort of
meanest toughest questions when I was
interviewing the seminars up on YouTube
so there's like proof that that happened
and so then I started my when I came
here after a brief stint
at MIT and I I came here started a group
largely thinking about electrification
mostly on vehicles and the sort of big
question that we were trying to answer
was was how can we design organic
electrolytes I think that was the one
piece that I felt there was a lot of art
to it
and we wanted to try and change that
process of of thinking about
electrolytes and so I'm not an organic
chemist so we thought about Big Data
along before Big Data was was sort of a
huge buzz word but I think you know
we've we've made phenomenal progress you
know I lead a team of about 20 other
accidental electro chemists and I think
they will all like this but that but I
think that's you know it's been
phenomenal to have a group of very
interesting mix from you know physics
Chemical Engineering Mackey material
science and so on so I think it's been a
great journey and and you know I look
forward to the next 10 years of my
career looking at you know battery 2.0 I
guess James years ago I was also
thinking about grad school just about to
enter I was actually excited for working
at a gas turbine engine manufacturer
I've always been interested in energy
storage energy conversion energy
generation and so I started off gas
turbine engines demo barrier coatings
and I saw this opportunity for fuel
cells and I ended up doing all my grad
school work on hydrogen fuel cells
particularly developing two solid
electrolytes and along the way the BIC
was just they were just building the
Foundation's at the time and near the
end they had opened the doors and I
started to hear this opportunity I'd
also spent all this time in grad school
on some very interesting work you know a
lot of people I ended up working at the
BIC worked on various fuel cells a
polymer is more more commonly me solid
oxide fuel cell certainly a very
efficient form and working on solid
electrolyte gave me some interesting
experience there but I wanted to be a
little bit closer
something in in a more practical use
widespread use I saw that and that
lithium-ion batteries had developed so
much and I saw that the BIC was in that
facilitator role that final hurdle to
take it from university to end-user to
help these help early researchers with
very minimal amounts of money access the
equipment that they need to prove their
technology on a larger scale large
enough that the big million cell per
year plus manufacturers are going to go
out there and and really look at them
seriously and trust the data from that
third party so it's a very exciting
opportunity and I did find that as I
mentioned a fair number of people that
I've worked with in the battery industry
now were fuel cell workers in the past I
think that's that's been a jump that
I've noticed is a lot of fuel cell
researchers kind of are jumping on board
the battery train both technologies of
course have very good application to the
future but here we're talking about
batteries and energy storage and that's
where I've started really was three and
a half years ago and in terms of
lithium-ion batteries and I would say
half of the work that we've done at the
BIC in that time has all been developing
various aspects of the silicon chemistry
from active material makers to binder
makers to electrolyte makers every every
little piece has really been necessary
and that can be the challenges everyone
has one of the pieces of the solution
and the big tries to make them share
that information but everyone of course
it's very difficult to develop a product
and protect your intellectual property
but I would say that most of the
individual pieces of the technology are
out there and that it's a matter of
sharing your information and you would
actually get there that would be high
silicon content commercial cells so I
mean you guys are a test house right so
you get these samples in or units in
from a variety of places and test them
yes we
I probably worked with maybe a dozen
different silicon anode developers they
send whatever piece of the prop of the
end cell that they make they send it to
us we work in some sort of collaborative
way they maybe come to the BIC as well
and we try to develop their cell as a
collaborative process and test it with a
independent party wolof between the
different competitors I presume though
yes it's a careful process but we've
managed we managed and then there's one
of the other things we try to do is if
there is something that's shared or the
opportunity to share we basically have
like a black box process you can put
your thing every company can put their
thing into the black box we don't tell
you what it is but we'll show you the
performance results after the fact and
if they're so stunning maybe you'll
start sharing that information and that
has actually happened in the past but
yeah for the most part silicon has been
where we've seen a lot of development
and electrolyte and high voltage
electrolytes okay it's been the big part
of the work I'd say I like the rest of
my co-panelists I was in school ten
years ago
finishing a PhD in mechanical
engineering had nothing to do with
batteries I knew I wanted to work on
energy wasn't quite sure where to go
with it brief detour through DC in a
policy fellowship decided I did not want
to go that route either really wanted to
go back to working on technology so I
had an opportunity to move to New York
City to lead an RPE research project
developing a new type of capacitor based
power converter DC to DC converter for
electricity and in that same lab there
was another RPE project working on a new
grid scale energy storage technology
based on alkaline materials so basically
taking the the cheap materials in a
Duracell battery and scaling it up
making them cyclically for grid
applications
so in that lab I was I was in my work I
was leading a team that was developing
capacitors were making lots of
prototypes were doing a lot of testing a
lot of data analysis and my counterpart
on the grid scale storage
a project was doing the same and you
know we had our group of developed some
very rudimentary tools to help us
accelerate those data analysis workflows
basically so we could look at the our
data in a web browser instead of having
to go into the lab and download it on a
USB stick put in a spreadsheet etcetera
and with apologies to our sponsors that
arpa-e it turned out that the those
software tools that we were working with
are actually generating a lot more
commercial interest than the energy
storage technologies that we were
developing on those grants they were
helping us get papers out faster get
patents out faster and we were actually
you know people who would come through
to visit the lab actually wanted to know
about how could could they get the
software that we were using rather than
you know could they license or partner
with the center of hardware you know so
we took that hint that there might be a
commercial opportunity to build a
software platform a software product
targeted specifically towards the
engineering analysis challenges in
batteries and energy storage and their
applications so that's what we did and
we you know early on we one of those one
of those inquiries about you know could
they get their hands on our software we
took that opportunity to do a sort of
one-off consulting project as a
proof-of-concept myself and my
co-founder the guy was leading the the
battery project who actually had
previously done fuel cells as well
before he moved over to batteries so we
did that proof-of-concept project we
raised SBIR grant money from Department
of Energy National Science Foundation to
get the company off the ground and sort
of scaled it from there and you know
here that was 2012 and here we are about
six years later and you know we're
working with companies sort of across
the spectrum of batteries and their
applications from early-stage R&D other
independent test centers automotive
companies consumer electronics sort of
you know we sort of found this
opportunity in this gigantic global
industry of batteries and energy storage
and their applications which in
aggregate is a huge global market and
there's really a need for dedicated
software tools in that market so that's
that's that's what we're building as a
company
voltaic I'd say the other thing you know
that early on led to this inspiration
was not being a battery person
originally and sitting in a lab at City
College of New York with a bunch of
other battery researchers I was hearing
people complain constantly about how the
state of the art of predictive models
for battery performance was terrible in
academia industry people are doing
trying all kinds of like supercomputer
simulations things like that and and not
really coming up with a lot of practical
results and so you know perhaps being
naive I I sort of asked the question
well is anybody taking the big data
approach and just trying to collect as
much data as you can and and be
empirical so look at the you know the
actual performance data of how these
batteries are performing as well as you
know all the metadata that you can get
about how they were built
what sort of process these materials etc
and it turned out that that nobody was
doing that and one of the big reasons
was that nobody could get enough data in
one place in order to you know get a
meaningful data set that would be useful
in that kind of study so that's sort of
the dual there's sort of two things that
we're focused on it voltaic is really
getting all that data into one place and
then doing interesting and valuable
things with it for our customers perfect
things so this is evidence that if you
want to work in batteries don't start
studying batteries you should move on to
something else
later on no I mean and this is one of
the main reasons I wanted to eat your
personal stories out a little bit is in
fact what's happened in the past decade
is that there was almost no battery
research in North America ten years ago
very little and there's been such an
influx of funding support interest in
indeed you know markets that have
evolved in the past decade that you've
seen these holes filled by people like
this who have seen the opportunity
responded to funding from the Delian and
RP in other places and have created
entire careers and industry around it so
it's super exciting that this whole
class of people for each one on the on
the stage before you there's tens and
tens and hundreds elsewhere in the
United States who are like them so this
is a huge movement that's occurred in
part because of folks like Dave
Danielson and others who have pulled the
trigger on a lot of funding and support
for energy story
so the need is there the perceived need
the real need and this is the answer to
those questions
all right so second question and we try
to go a little bit faster here now that
we sort of set the stage
what is battery 2.0 when I say battery
2.0 to you what does it mean okay I have
some ideas about this and I'll try to go
quickly to your point battery 1.0 to me
was technology driven I think that the
major innovations that will happen will
be led by the market need this time and
that means that there's going to be
sophisticated techno economic modeling
that starts from the beginning and
considers the full landed system I'm
thinking mostly stationary batteries
here but probably also in cars I will be
market needs driven for the innovations
and that that market need will drive the
technology development process I think
that for there's my two classes of
battery 2.0 high-performing and very
very low cost and in particular for very
low cost I think that battery 2.0 will
not really have synthetic chemicals
involved it's going to be simple
naturally occurring very abundant
materials because we need to go down an
order of magnitude more in cost Thank
You 2.0 I try to I'll try to get to this
as fast as possible so to get to 2.0 we
need to know where 1.0 darkness and and
so I think largely this is sort of my
current thesis one point with 1.0 we
will electrify nearly all markets of
transportation including heavy duty
trucking with some slight changes in
behavior and probably with some
enhancements and charging which will
happen so which means then the question
is we know what is 2.0 and and for me
personally you know I think the the
biggest the biggest omission at least
from a personal stance standpoint is
flying
I fly a hundred thousand miles a year
not proud of it and my body doesn't like
it and so we would like to try and
Electrify planes I think it's not as
hard as it might imagine so I think
that's one
of battery 2.0 at least personally the
second thing which I think gets to many
of the things that people have been
talking about is in the battery business
the problem is when people tell you
something
there's people tell you many things all
of which could be true but they're all
never simultaneously true and and so as
a result there's sort of a huge mistrust
in the battery field and I think part of
this is is that it's a hard problem
you know multiphysics multi-dimensional
and so on so I think data is going to be
a key layer as we go forward and so I
think having data fill the gap and and
be the sort of driver of innovation
towards all these next-generation
chemistry's either for sort of high
performance for aviation or other
markets and for things like you know
long-duration storage I think data and
sort of high performance markets are
sort of two things that I think 2.0
batteries will be about James so I'm
getting the impression we're talking a
step change now kind of beating off of
what the previous panelists have said
battery 2.0 is a step change from where
we're at now some some new application
real change not just the incremental
improvements that we've been talking
about as far as higher nickel content or
listening to weight lowering the cost as
you've said yet fundamentally lowering
the cost would be a battery 2.0 and I
still think that battery 1.0 still has a
lot of legroom in the in the sense that
we're talking here the cathode
theoretical capacities there's still a
lot left in the tanks there and even
integration of things like the
conversion based anodes not necessarily
a step change just another larger
increment of improvement and so to me
battery 2.0 would actually possibly
involve a fundamental change in the
manufacturing processes themselves right
now we're pretty much just in the
process we have now because of magnetic
tape decks
in the 80s and CDs in the 90s a whole
lot of equipment came offline
someone found spigot out a way to use
that equipment for something that could
make some money with it and we just keep
on making all these incremental changes
with it and when I think of the truly
next-generation energy storage
technologies some of them are not
entirely compatible with this tape
casting method that we use now where we
have solid particles and the interfaces
of solid particles are difficult to
control
I'm sure there's everyone's barely aware
of the solid electrolyte interface
issues and columbic efficiency issues
that ultimately lead to poor shelf life
and poor cycle life and many other
problems these are all surface science
these are all interface issues and they
all come back to the manufacturing
process now there's certainly plenty of
incremental changes we can do to improve
it different electrolytes high voltage
electrolytes additives all these things
are battery 1.0 though battery 2.0 is
more likely to be in my mind something
like a solid-state battery which would
probably involve a different
manufacturing process since the inherent
porosity created in traditional
manufacturing is not entirely compatible
with ideal solid-state chemistry
so it should surprise knowing that my
vision for battery 2.0 involves data
it's very heavily data centric and I
appreciate banquettes remarks run along
those lines but to flesh that out a
little further what we see is you know
if you look at batteries today every
battery that's doing anything you know
even remotely valuable or important is
is generating data whether it's in a
test lab whether it's during the
manufacturing process during the
formation cycling that happens towards
the end of that process whether it's
being integrated into a product you or
used in an application or then repurpose
at the end of life there is data being
collected on those batteries all across
that chain and so our vision for battery
2.0 is really to connect those dots
throughout the the full lifecycle of a
battery so that you have sort of
traceability of that battery's origin
and how its performed and sort of what
its health and what its quality is
throughout that lifecycle and you know
we we sort of see that in our work with
our customers sort of being pulled in
that direction it's sort of both up and
down the supply chain in terms of there
being a desire for more data exchange
and transparency between the material
suppliers and manufacturers
manufacturers and the you know consumer
electronics or electric vehicle
applications and then even once they
ship those products out the door with
the financial community that's gonna be
insuring those fleets of vehicles or
those batteries on the grid at scale so
we sort of see data as the layer that
connects all those dots and and can
facilitate that future vision perfect so
I've got one more general question for
you guys and we'll break it down to
individual questions or questions from
the audience so please if you're
thinking of things enter them now speak
now or forever hold your peace a couple
years ago I was drafted to a National
Academies panel and I did an assessment
of arpa-e part of the exercise was to
assess their energy storage portfolio
and at the time they had circuit 2015
they had funded 63 separate storage
related projects to the tune of
somewhere between 200 and 250 million
dollars depending on how you
caution at the same time do you we had
founded you know a variety of centers
the biggest one in which of G is JC's er
that's hosted at Argonne National Lab
and so that was a big sort of focal
point of the UE along with all these
different projects of more innovation
centric at arpa-e an NSF had a handful
of things as well so there is a general
huge uptick in funding from the US
government that spurned a lot of this as
I mentioned the question that I have you
guys is and we've all benefited from it
one way or another is this still going
in the right direction
this should R&D policy or R&D around
energy storage or batteries be altered
given all we've talked about battery 1.0
a battery 2.0 knowing that in Asia there
are you know in it there are rooms with
hundreds of PhDs who are doing
incremental improvement on the current
technologies and they are doing it in a
brutal way that is hard to compete with
what happens here to do the next thing
that's gonna matter that's gonna move
the bar and is this an R&D function for
the government or is this something that
should be more or venture based I think
in the spectrum of R&D what I would like
to see more of is focus on the D the
development portion of it and in
particular I think about a learning
curve like a right curve where the total
volume of production is correlated to an
exponential price decline and in order
to achieve the value of that learning
curve we need to produce the volume and
so lithium-ion has that advantage it is
producing at volumes that are increasing
year over year if we're going to see new
technologies compete we have to give
them a shot at more than the our level
and and that has to be a national
priority if we are going to be the ones
that are going to capture that flag in
the United States it certainly is a
national priority in China for instance
they're making an 800 megawatt hour flow
battery and you know will it cost down I
don't know but the only way to find out
is to you know is to fund the
development effort as well as the
research ever
just to follow up on that I think there
needs to be sort of more crosstalk
between R and D I think there's a lot of
people that work a lot on either R or
either D and I think there's very little
crosstalk in my own experience and I
think some of my students will attest to
this when you have that link to folks
that are that are constantly thinking
about development that fundamentally
changes your landscape in terms of how
you think about research how you think
about framing your question and and you
sort of know whether what you do will
ever make a difference and I think
that's a really important thing that I
think some of the agencies like goe and
RPE encourage of course the challenge
with many of that kind of funding comes
sort of challenging milestones and
deliverables that you know this is
sometimes hard to predict with such
ambitious projects and and obviously
when you want to try and bring anything
new you have to also assume that the
current technology is going to get so
much better and so you have to assume
that you can beat them five years from
now so I think there are some pieces
that are very good with how RPE
and and do e elements that they have in
their funding model but they're I think
taking a longer-term view is of course
challenging but I think would be
something that would greatly benefit
these sorts of very ambitious projects
all right I think I'm definitely
agreeing on a particularly the rnd
separation there that's definitely
something at the BIC that we've seen a
lot where you know in coin-cell testing
for instance seems like they solve every
problem you could imagine and they're so
satisfied with that result and then they
try to scale it up and and often times
that coin sale result was fairly
meaningless by coin cell just to be
clear for the audience these are very
very tiny test cells there are tens of
milligrams of active
but it proves function and it's very
easy the wrong word but it's more common
to get stellar results from something
small but of course you have several
orders of magnitude more area the same
material even in a regular battery and
then much more difficult right exactly
exactly and the the the free volume
available in that cell is so much more
as far as the coin cell is concerned the
electrolyte to active mass ratio there's
just so many things that on a more
geometric basis for that format just
don't translate very well and
additionally as far as the funding site
goes I do because as the BIC we I don't
often look to get our own grants we
usually partner with different entities
that have you know some piece of
technology and we'll partner with them
on a grant to to facilitate it and so
we've seen a whole lot of different
applications and the ones that succeed
and don't and I would generally I
generally think that the better ones do
tend to succeed although the ones that
promise the most to get the grants the
most as well which is which is some some
of what of a challenge I think but
that's hard to hard to fight against
obviously the person promising the most
is the most enticing or the biggest liar
yeah the most optimistic you can just be
I like to be I like to be positive and
just say they were the most optimistic
researchers but yes I do think that that
step between early research and later
development and scale-up it could be
bridged a lot more and that's really
what the book is all about was what's
creating that bridge and I think we've
had some success in that great so I'm
gonna echo a couple of things that that
were said just now which is that I think
a major priority going forward for
battery R&D is to develop metrics so
that you can actually compare different
technologies on a level playing field
and so broadly speaking you know when
you're developing a new battery
technology things are concerned with our
how much energy can it hold how much
power
deliver how long can you cycle it how
many times can you charge and discharge
it how much does it cost and how safe is
it and so you know I think that it would
be great if there were some priority
around developing a standard set of
metrics to evaluate every technology
along those different axes it would be
fairly straightforward to propose you
know for different applications where
there's transportation for its storage
etc which ones are more important how
they should be weighted but you know
it's sort of I think that there's an
issue in that you hear so often in the
media the sort of the stories that
bubble up to the media about the newest
battery breakthrough it somebody has a
technology that can you know will be
able to charge your car in 10 seconds
your electric vehicle in 10 seconds or
what have you but almost invariably
there's some one of those acts one or
more of those axes of performance is
sort of being hidden and not talked
about and those are important very
relevant and so I think some you know
making it a priority in terms of
research funding where those resources
go being able to evaluate these things
so you can separate out sort of the the
science projects or the you know the
hero cells where you have one battery
that runs for 10,000 cycles you have no
idea why but from the ones who can
generate statistically significant
results that can be compared and and
used to make those those priority
decisions perfect and I've got actually
Madden want to I want to pull you in
here for a second I want you to dial
back yourself a good eight or nine years
what you might not know him as that he
was at General Electric for a little
while how many years two years due to
very long years yes yeah and you're on
the DGE dureth on battery team so you
this is sort of it's an interesting
historical I'm gonna bring this into to
a corporate R&D for batteries just that
just so you know but GE bought purchased
a company called beta battery right and
then they decided they were gonna scale
this is a high temperature what was it a
nickel sodium sodium yes it a nickel
chloride battery and they poured how
much money into it hundreds of millions
yeah at least
so millions into manufacturing the team
the you have the clean rooms everything
and what happened it's no longer
operable that's right and and so I get
my question really is corporate wise the
GES of the world I mean are they diving
back in the new batteries or not like
what's where do people stand so I I
don't think so I don't think we're gonna
see any personally I don't think you're
gonna see any big you know fortune 100
company that's gonna go and start
research from the ground up I think what
all those big companies are doing is
hoping that either something gets
through like Ted said right the D part
of it where they can go out and deploy
or they're very content right now just
to buy off-the-shelf lithium-ion cells
from whoever's the lowest cost supplier
packaged them together and sell it for
whatever margin they can yeah I don't
think they'll you'll see any research
coming out of the big companies yeah and
the other indicator is Sony actually the
first company to market lithium-ion
batteries Sony is sort of divesting
their battery assets there's getting out
of the business it's a sort of seen as a
race to the bottom low margin high risk
kind of situation so as we think about
R&D and moving forward there's this open
question well who's gonna take over the
tech and and you know if we have
something that's so different a new
chemistry solid-state that requires a
different manufacturing infrastructure
who's gonna own that who's gonna put up
the multiple billions to overcome so
there's this tension between incremental
improvement of our current that you know
approach and then the opposite which is
this sort of if you're gonna make a
difference in a radical way who's gonna
foot the bill
we've got breakthrough energy ventures
and other folks like that we're willing
to cede and support for years but can
they convert can they make the thing
this is gonna be an interesting question
about battery 2.0 I think the story is
largely about converting to that like
large-scale production of things we have
about five minutes left one of the
audience questions discuss raw material
supply issues as bad as as we scale
batteries globally what do you guys
think the raw materials pain points are
Dave mentioned in his talk cobalt and
lithium
is this true and is there something else
we should be looking at as well
anybody thank you so III think some of
this is overstated obviously cobalt is
the most challenging I think at least
one way I think about it is is you you
you have to sort of think about whether
the control of production of that
particular material is is controlled by
one country or many countries and so for
nearly all other materials including
lithium and and we're not gonna run sure
the lithium the simple arithmetic that
you can do all you need is one mole of
lithium and one mole of transition metal
lithium is so light so you you can do a
back-of-the-envelope looking back at
your periodic table and know that you
know you need one tenth of lithium for
transition metals so lithium is likely
not going to be the bottleneck cobalt
may be there there are many options
related to sort of low cobalt so of
course I think this is a challenge but I
don't think this is something that it's
going to be a huge showstopper yeah and
I could I could add to that I would
agree and I think though that where it
blends together with where it can be
challenging is the price fluctuation
it's the industry is large enough now
that you know the mining consortiums are
actually going to these you know battery
shows and they're paying attention to
the industry since there's so much being
bought now that it actually affects the
decisions on whether to open up and
mined more I definitely think it
particularly nickel and and the others
other than cobalt that as demand
increases supply will follow you'll have
those delays that you can have just like
you know even with oiled sometimes
supply and demand don't quite match up
and the price skyrockets I think that's
one case where batteries have a little
bit more flexibility an example would be
cell died dissected recently it was
technically they were lying about the
cell but still it worked if the cell
worked they just lied about what was in
it
lco recently got very much more
expensive and so they blended in NMC
and it
the same performance characteristics it
worked they should have been honest
about it but still it leads to what you
can do when we have these flexible
chemistry's if one particular element
suddenly gets expensive we can shift
among a few choice and just for the
audience newcomers to batteries LCL is
lithium cobalt oxide NMC is lithium
nickel cobalt manganese oxide and they
have different ratios and the idea is to
play the game of reducing the amount of
expensive things like cobalt and nickel
while increasing the amount of manganese
without having a crappy battery and
there's it's funny how nature works
there that the cheaper the material the
worse the battery oftentimes and then I
don't know how that how they know yeah
well the world knows the whole industry
is just is trade off every time you see
a strange one performance metric you're
usually sacrificing another widget where
you're leading before is you know even
with traditional chemistry's you can
make a special form of that battery that
will make one stat look amazing yeah so
maybe time for one more question and I'm
trying to sort of hear one thing that's
also an undercurrent right now from a
research perspective going forward I
think in all in all areas that we talk
about especially here at CMU is
computational powers and machine
learning is a big data is an assessment
is it materials discovery there's so
many different flavors of it and I know
we're chasing in here in multiple areas
within CMU and maybe you think I comment
a little bit on that but how about you
other folks to a what is the future of
all this new computational power that
we're seeing coming online how is this
going to impact what we do so last
question good online one observation I
had about about that when I said that
technology development will be market
driven there's stuff that is possible
today that we just never could have done
10-15 years ago for example on the
market side we can now get multiple
20-year data sets hourly resolution wind
and make some assumptions about
different battery characteristics and
run a techno-economic model to run
optimizing scenarios for what
combination
of solar plus storage or wind plus
storage or both creates the cost
minimizing levelized cost of electricity
that kind of stuff was never possible
before and that that helps us tease out
new sets of market requirements that
feed into the product development
process we can say how important is
efficiency and you know one striking
realization we had was that if you're
looking in a to a future where there's a
1 cent per kilowatt hour PPA efficiency
is less important than we thought and
relaxing that design constraint can
really change your options for
technology development and that that
kind of market-based computation just
was not possible and just be clear when
Ted says we he means the form energy
team informant and by the way it was the
first investment of from Dave Danielson
steam and BV so it's an ultra long
duration storage and they're figuring
out a way to sit to crack that at that
problem so we have just a minute left or
or less so please fast and concise eli
is probably going to talk about data so
I'm gonna talk about the the piece
related to being able to do everything
on the computer never have to test and
then the experiment is just validation
and you might think this is pie in the
sky idea but the steel industry has
gotten there with CalFire the
thermodynamics models are so good that
in experimentation is largely validation
where are we on getting there with
batteries but we're not there yet the
materials project has made phenomenal
progress at sort of collecting the data
and trying to sort of build that piece
but in 10 years I would be very
surprised if we cannot with 99% accuracy
predict the voltage curve of any battery
material I will be very quick because I
don't do a lot of software and just
agree with you that that that's where
the direction would go so let's see two
quick things one thing that we see
happening is you know we think that
right now it's happening with lithium
the costs are going down things are
becoming commoditized we see that
following a similar sort of trajectory
to the semiconductor market over the
last couple decades where they went from
being a very expensive relatively rare
to now they're ubiquitous and generally
speaking very cheap very low margin
business hard
business there's a tremendous amount of
optimisation to be done in throughout
that supply chain and manufacturing
chain that's can be enabled by computers
and data analysis and then the second
thing that I'll say is in terms of
deploying these systems at scale
somebody needs to pay for them they need
to be financed they need to be insured
all that capital hates uncertainty
there's still a tremendous amount of
uncertainty around how these systems are
going to perform in the field so again
going back to the data thing it's gonna
be about collecting a lot of data and
then being able to model that and model
the financial implications of the actual
physical state of the battery not just
modeling what the sort of how you
optimize when you charge and discharge
to maximize the revenues all right well
without taking up any more time I want
to thank you guys I wanna I wanna I want
to throw a last question back to you or
so that I think everyone wants to know
what battery 2.0 in Jays mind is so I
think we should close with that that's
it so it's a fair question wow I I don't
know yet actually I'm thinking about
battery 3.0 I'm sitting battery 2.0 out
and I'm waiting for you guys to do that
and then I will follow up with battery
3.0 in about six or seven years no I
think that to be honest with you I think
that the answer is some hybrid of what
Ted is going after and what some of the
lithium-ion folks are going after I
think we have to find a battery 2.0 for
me because of the incredible pressure
from a manufacturing infrastructure
perspective to devote immense capital to
scale down to cost we have to design
batteries that are useful for both
stationary and mobile applications
somehow and this is hard to do because
then an optimized battery for a car is
totally different than a battery without
demise for stationary storage right now
and if we could find a way to create a
Silver Bullet chemistry or cell
configuration or something that will
allow for both of those markets to be
served perfectly or well because right
now like Tesla solution of putting its
battery cells into a package a hanging
on a wall is not actually a good
stationary storage plate just it's not I
mean it it's great the Tesla's doing it
in their popularizing the idea but
electrochemically it's
the right answer so battery 2.0 in my
mind or maybe 3.0 is something that is
both that can do both things because
you'd love to leverage the two you know
the two markets and people talk about
doing it now but it's more difficult so
with that thank our audience
[Applause]
so you guys well thank you very much
so our next panel today those folks are
joining us on stage so as they do that
good afternoon my name is Ana Stefan and
I'm with the Scot Institute for energy
innovation we're going to move right
into our next panel we have two panels
before our next break and this panel is
on the insights and innovations in
natural gas and traditional fuels so our
moderator for this session I'm very
honored to introduce
so dr. Jared L Cohen is the president
emeritus and university professor of
civil and environmental engineering and
engineering and public policy and he's
the Wilton a Scott Institute for energy
innovation director emeritus at Carnegie
Mellon University dr. Cohen will be the
moderator of this panel and he served as
Carnegie Mellon's eighth president from
1997 to 2013 during that time the
university made progress on many fronts
including teaching and research
international activities diversity and
economic development in southwest
Pennsylvania dr. Cohen is the former
director of CMU's Wilton East Scott
Institute for energy innovation morgan
o'brien also joins us he's closest to me
here he's the president and chief
executive officer of people's natural
gas company LLC he is in this capacity
he's responsible for the company's
strategic operational and financial
performance under his leadership
people's mission is to make the lives of
all of its customers better Pat Getty
has been the president of the Claud
Worthington Benedum foundation since
1999 in addition to his vision shared
board position he's a member of the
governing board of imagine West Virginia
vision shared s-- independent Policy
Institute he also serves on the policy
committee of the southwestern
Pennsylvania Commission and is a fellow
of the University of Pittsburgh
Institute of Politics michaelm are
joined us from shell Pennsylvania
chemicals where he is the business
innovation lead he's been both a senior
communications leader in both of the
private and public sector for more than
two decades in 2012 Marr joined shell
and has since worked in different roles
covering shells u.s. chemical assets and
shells petrochemical project in Beaver
County Pennsylvania
Stacy Olsen in the center is the
president of Chevron Appalachia LLC a
position she assumed in June of 2016
she's responsible for developing leading
Chevron for leading Chevron's business
unit that develops natural
from shale in Pennsylvania Ohio and West
Virginia Olsen also is a board member of
both the Center for Responsible shale
development and the Allegheny conference
on community development david
Ruppersberger is here he's the president
of the pittsburgh regional alliance an
affiliate of the Allegheny conference
for community development he's been
active in the Pittsburgh high-tech
community for over 30 years his
experience includes senior management
positions with Unisys Symbolics
and carnegie group inc CEO positions for
two high-tech startups in the pittsburgh
area and a partnership in a retail
business he served on many local boards
and is an executive fellow in the Center
for Economic Development at Carnegie
Mellon's Heinz College and he has a
degree in economics from the universe
University of Pittsburgh and with that
I'd like to welcome all of our esteemed
panelists for our session Gerry I'll
send it over to you thank you very much
Hannah and thank you all for being here
for this panel the Marcellus Shale
formation is the largest shale gas
formation in the country largest in the
sense of potential for producing an
actual gas as you know well anybody from
this region
it's a formation that we've been
exploiting now for about ten years I
guess in earnest and we will continue
for many decades to come one of the
questions is and the central question is
what are the benefits and what are the
costs in this region of the development
of that Marcellus shale resource are we
realizing the benefits and we maximizing
the benefits that we can get from that
resource
are we minimizing the cost or at least
containing the cost today we're going to
explore that with these outstanding
panels it's a really a wonderful group
that will complement each other very
well as you will hear as we proceed
let's start with you pat pat getty from
the bend
datian who sought a lot about this
question of getting the most out of the
Marcellus Shale resource how this region
can most benefit from it and I should
add and reinforce in cue that that he's
thought about this from a truly regional
perspective not just western
Pennsylvania
not just Pennsylvania but fact
Pennsylvania Ohio West Virginia yeah
give us your thoughts about this thank
you I
the Benedum foundation has what for a
long time was just a curious geography
we serve all of West Virginia and
southwestern Pennsylvania but with the
advent of the shale opportunity that
that curious geography has become pretty
relevant we've been able to engage in in
regional efforts to try to truly in my
mind try to maximize the opportunity
which I think the front of my once
described by saying that prosperity
flows to where value is added to a raw
material and I can assure you every West
Virginian understands this essentially
for Earth because they've seen that the
value the prosperity creation from coal
happen in places like Pittsburgh and
Cleveland and Detroit and what they're
left with is the the decline in jobs and
whatever the impacts in health and
environmental have been that's the way
West Virginia to see it so they really
understand that with this gas being
underfoot what is really important it's
not just a guerrilla shipment but to
actually add value to it in the region
and I'm convinced that the region has a
generational opportunity to develop
modern manufacturing around products
that are at least in part temper
chemical and origin things like carbon
fibers all kinds of endeavor it won't be
manufacturing like I knew 72 years ago
when I was born here but I think it's a
tremendous opportunity and I think we
tend to focus on Carnegie Mellon and
Pitt UPMC obviously if we're in
Pittsburgh but if you get outside of
Allegheny County the region is not
prospering this is really a chance to
change that and so that's that's on the
benefit side for sure as I would say
thanks been actually taking this sort of
a layer deeper Stacy Stacy
Elson the regional head of chevron you
joined forces with people's gas to do a
study but just this question of how to
maximize the benefits from shale gas
production forging the future you call
it could you tell us about that what
your findings were what your
recommendations were sure so let me just
say that it's not just large gas
resource for the u.s. it's one of the
largest scarce resources in the entire
world so it is truly truly significant
as you said last year Morgan and I
teamed up and we we work with a
consultant to really try and quantify
this question of what is the true
economic potential and that's important
now because only a fraction of the
resource has actually been produced so
if you're going to try and maximize the
economic benefit now is the time and
what we found was it quantified that
there was the potential for sixty
billion dollars of GDP growth 500,000
family-sustaining jobs and as much as
three billion dollars in tax revenue to
the state if the right strategies could
be put in place to maximize the
long-term economic value from the
resource I'm gonna move now to Dave
Ruppersberger so you heard Davis from
the Pittsburgh regional alliance and not
everybody knows what that is just to
help you understand suppose you're a
company in Seattle and you were thinking
about opening a second headquarters just
suppose you would go to the Pittsburgh
region Alliance to flecked out whether
Pittsburgh was for you not to put you on
the spot Dave but you'll be happy to
know today's agenda is not about amazon
but you're out there and you've got a
sense I think better than any of us of
this kind of overall opportunities and
barriers to downstream development
related natural gas tell us what you
know so we've been focused primarily on
an aspect of the natural gas that not
everybody and other regions has the
advantage
we do our gas is wet gas so from
Marysville West about 25% of what comes
out of the grounds the combination of
ethane propane and butane which surely
can be used as fuel sources just as the
drying methane can but it also serves as
a feedstock for chemicals so the ethane
gets turned to ethylene and then the
polyethylene which is what she'll is
going to be doing similar fashion you
can take propane into propylene and
polypropylene and make plastics
materials with that those are markets
that are growing nationally and
internationally I tend to think that you
should look more regionally for those
markets because most of its transported
in pipelines so in North America for
instance we use about 3.4 million
barrels of natural gas liquids every day
and that's projected to double about
2026 so a lot of growth in that market
in particular we have some also some
advantages here I want to point out
about our F ain in particular we have a
lot of it right now we're exporting
almost all of it in fact we are
exporting all of it except for what
we're burning is fuel but we have enough
ethane here to supply the shell cracker
continue to export exactly what we're
exporting now and we have enough left
over for four or five more crackers the
scale of shell the other thing is it's
the cheapest ethane in the world it's
estimated we have about a 30% cost
advantage over any other ethane in the
world which means we can take it and we
can do things with it as Pat was
alluding to add value create plastic
pellets and ship them anywhere in the
world with the possible exception of
China more cheaply than anybody else can
but the other advantage we have is we
don't need to ship excuse me to foreign
markets because 700 within 700 miles of
the shell cracker is 70% of the North
American marketplace the product that
they're going to produce so that's a
huge advantage as well
so go I want to make sure so what are
the things I know the Alliance is part
of the conference focuses on a lot is
the regional labor force and the kinds
of downstream job downstream development
your timeout requires a particular labor
force to support it what's the take on
that supply do we have the people we
need to support those jobs so there's
actually a part that comes before that
which is do we have enough labor to
build it and that was a real challenge
for us and as an economic developer we
don't often talk about a union labor
when we're trying to recruit people to
Pittsburgh but I can tell you without a
doubt that this project would not have
been completed without the full support
of 12 trade unions in Pittsburgh they
pulled together got the work force
together convinced shale that if they
didn't have enough people they could
train enough people to make this happen
once its operational there's another six
hundred people very highly technical
jobs they're gonna be required inside
defense to support this but probably two
or three times that many jobs outside
the fence in other supply chain oriented
companies and we're working very hard
with partners like the Beaver County
Community College other partners in the
region to make sure that the workforce
is there and I'm sure Michael couldn't
help on that as well be natural this
segue to Michael and shell but before we
do I want to sort of lay out the full
extent of the downstream opportunities
and call out Morgan Morgan O'Brien the
president CEO of people's gas to tell us
a bit about the retail side but also
Morgan this audience would not
necessarily know though a lot of car to
keep people hurting development people
would Morgan Morgan's been a real
visionary when it comes to environmental
side of the retail distribution of
natural gas and I want to make sure you
say something about the partnership
we've got what's emu on methane weeks
but so the retail side in the
our mental leakage so yeah I think on
the retail side I mean I think Stacy
started with a you know the study that
we did in having a real analytics around
the potential and one of the areas that
we know is evident is that about more
than half of the people who live in the
state of Pennsylvania don't have access
to natural gas which in a state that's
housing the largest gas reserve in the
entire country and and one of the
largest in the world it feels like
that's clearly a huge opportunity both
for the market to develop here but also
to make sure that everybody in
Pennsylvania has access to it and has
the ability to enjoy the benefits and
and we literally two years ago started
going in it these are mostly talking
rural communities here
I know it's close to Pat's heart but
these are communities that are you know
lower to middle class and they can save
on average between the thousands of
$1500 a year in heaney costs by
converting to gas and so it's a it's a
huge economic opportunity for I'll say
the average person to have a meaningful
benefit coming from all this incredible
gas that we have but the other side of
it is as people start thinking about and
I was interested in the the mayor of San
Juan who was here talking about the grid
and the reliability my background was 20
years at Duquesne Light before I came
the peoples and the idea of creating
micro grids and the ability to take this
natural gas because it's so plentiful so
reliable it's produced right here and
utilize that to convert it to gas and
we're starting to see more and more of
folks thinking about that aspect as well
as when we hear about nuclear and coal
and the challenges there the opportunity
to grow the grid with more gas being
generated here and being at truly
economic when I came over from from
Duquesne Light
I dared describe me as visionary I
actually would describe myself as being
scared I was so excited about the
economic opportunities for the region
and to be able to play a part in that as
a utility the biggest fear I had is that
I would screw it up and that my company
would screw it up under my leadership
and so one of the first things we did
was we reached out as I tell folks to
the smartest people I know which are the
folks here at Carnegie Mellon University
this is not a paid advertisement it's
literally the first folks we reach that
- and and what our our I'll say our
focus had never been and we knew it had
to be were on all the environmental
issues not with necessarily fracking and
the production of gas but literally
distributing it through the streets of
Pittsburgh and through all the
communities where everybody lives and we
knew I mean I knew the issues of having
old infrastructure having been at
Duquesne Light having lived in western
Pennsylvania seeing the bridges and the
roads and knowing all the infrastructure
issues that this part of the country has
we also have old water and gas lines
underground that we don't think about
and so for us we began immediately
accelerating the replacement of that old
pipe and X and replacing it as quickly
as we could as fast as we could manage
it but we really didn't have our hands
around what were those environmental
issues from having all this old pipe and
so through a partnership with Carnegie
Mellon University we've literally been
over the last couple years been going up
and down the streets of Pittsburgh
measuring the methane emissions coming
from our old pipes and that was really
important for us to understand one this
is a real issue it's an important issue
for people who live in this community
and if we didn't address it and take
ownership of it there's a strong
likelihood we're gonna screw this
opportunity up and so the folks at CMU
we've really integrated them into what
we call our risk management process
where we prioritize pipeline replacement
historically for a hundred years it's
based purely on reliability trying to
make sure we're reliable getting people
their gas we began a new priority
which overlaid that with the
environmental issues so where we had
significant environmental issues all of
a sudden a piece of pipe went high up on
the the pecking order for replacing that
pipe we also had the folks from CMU
measure the impacts on the on the air
that we're breathing from the pipe line
replacement so it was really a
before-and-after and so we're at the
point now where we're going to begin
literally describing to the communities
that we're serving one the issues that
were causing by having these old pipes
and then the benefits of the pipe line
replacement on the air that we're
breathing the the next phase which the
folks from seeing you I think from the
beginning were anxious to do was not
just to help us prioritize the old pipe
based on leakage but actually be able to
predict before we had leakage the
replacement of those pipes and so that's
really the next phase of our partnership
which is really exciting so this is not
fixing environmental issues but avoiding
those environmental issues and so we're
I don't think it's visionary and I think
it's fear of screwing up everything
these folks are talking about but it's
been incredibly enlightening to people
in my industry and my the people that
are working for me to have some really
smart I'll call them kids because I'm an
old person coming into our offices
sitting down with our engineers and
educating them and and and our folks
embracing it which was obviously an
important part of this but we truly I
think are creating a different priority
system from a utility perspective then
I'd say most utilities have ever had and
III that's why I'm here today I can't
say enough about Carnegie Mellon and an
incredible asset that it is for this
region oh thanks for the promotion but
whether it was fear or vision the key
thing was you innovate and innovation
affects daily the production side but
also the environment
in packs I didn't if it's a great
demonstration it's a good segue to
Michael Mann from shale chemicals and as
you all know and as you've heard already
shale is building a very large cracker
facility up in in Beaver County and I
happen to know just from prior
interactions with Michael that shale
takes this idea of innovation in
Environmental Protection very seriously
I it's important to lay the groundwork
though first you can't do these things
about having some environmental impact
can't distribute guess you can't produce
gas and you can't use the gas downstream
in producing products without having
some and viral impact but what you can
do is to be innovative and do your best
to minimize those impacts so Michael
tell us what you're doing with your
grantee matically on what Morgan was
speaking of and and how companies are
really incentivized both for
environmental and then economic reasons
to do a more thorough and better job of
keeping their products in the pipe and
and you know preserving them so that
they can be produced into something as
Pat said that's value adding so I'll
talk a little bit about a typical
manufacturing facility could either be a
refinery or chemical plant and then talk
about how we're doing things a little
bit differently
where we're innovating to offer an
environmental benefit to the region and
ultimately we believe an economic
benefit to us as well so typical
manufacturing facility will have a flare
which is a safety and environmental
device where you have an operational
upset to relieve pressure from that
operational upset you send a stream of
gas or some mode of product up the flare
to relieve the pressure situation that's
occurring literally at the ground level
and most of the emissions but not all
most of the emissions are burned off at
the flare so and and 98 99 % when I say
most but still when you have a foot a
flaring incident that
one that goes for a long time at a plan
of a large scale the emissions numbers
that have to be reported to the
regulator are typically pretty large so
what we did at this point was we
developed sort of an internal pipeline
network where we will circulate the
ethane if we have an upset and and we'll
be able to do this for approximately 24
hours so if you have a situation in a
plant where in within a shift or a shift
or two they're typically on 12-hour
shifts you could you could fix the
whatever the issue was that was causing
the upset we will have circulated the
ethane not have all the emissions that
would have been reported and well
there's an upfront cost for us to build
that on the back end
after years of operating there'll be a
benefit cuz we wouldn't have wasted all
the bad thing that we will events to
send to the flare so that's not
something that you would typically see
down on the Gulf Coast or other parts of
the world it is I know it involves pipes
and an industry that people don't
normally think about innovative but it
is a way we've looked at things
differently and see how we can offer
both an environmental benefit to the
region immediately and ultimately an
economic benefit to us as well even
Michael I want to come back to the
downstream development part of this I'm
sure the environmental side will come up
later as well and come back to you pad
and you Stacy get a little more specific
about the kinds of strategies or steps
we ought to be taking as a region to
maximize that benefit now Pat I know
you've worked to get the three states to
collaborate cooperate together you say
so more about that what kind of
cooperation there is going on within the
region yeah be glad to actually the the
governor's at Pennsylvania West Union
Ohio signed an agreement in October 2015
to collaborate around downstream
economic development and that agreement
was just free up for another three years
the week before last in Houston and
that's very unusual in Mike's
and not all that many years ago the
Benedum foundation annual report was on
the issue can regionalism ever happened
and the conclusion of the experts we
interviewed was probably not and there's
something like an opportunity to turn
things around but one of the main
projects that's going to be critical in
the development is creating storage
infrastructure and I have to call on
Brian Anderson who's the smartest guy I
know who's not on the faculty of
Carnegie Mellon who's a leader in
developing the assessment was done by
the Geological Survey offices of the
three states as to where storage could
happen and in the Gulf Coast storage is
there and easy for people to use and we
need something comparable of that to be
able to store the NGLs in the region
that raw materials for downstream
manufacturing and it also permits the
opportunity for the price to be
stabilized and so forth so I can't speak
to it nearly as well as Brian could but
it is a an ongoing significant effort
and if that is accomplished I think that
that'll certainly be a turning of the
tide as far as the future of downstream
manufacturing in the region it's a
critically important piece of
infrastructure happily the Secretary of
Energy Rick Perry has been very
supportive I was in a meeting in
Morgantown when the secretary came to
Morgantown we were all holding our
breath and the first thing he said was
you folks need to be like people in
Texas you got to add value to your raw
material here in the region you know and
everybody kind of breathed a sigh of
relief it was afraid to say anything
because we got you know he opened the
meeting with where we were hoping it
would end but I I do think for now the
stars are aligned to try to pull this
together that's going to be important so
who's who's our lead in making this
storage happens it's a there's a role
for state government state governments
working together or is it industry
taking lead with the Commerce
Department's have been been very
collaborative I think that's been that's
been important I think
eventually this will have to be funded
through private equity it's not an
expensive development and where the
project is now is in the engineering
stage the geologic survey offices prove
that it could be done now the question
is you know where and and obviously this
is going to be a long and debatable
process to go through permitting on this
but the piping is underground the
storage facilities are also underground
it's not a it's not a noticeable piece
of infrastructure for the most part but
it is critical you've got to be able to
move the the NGOs around the region so
that manufacturing can take place in
different locations but I think the
there is interest in and there is a
storage facility in Ohio that goldman
sachs has an interest in so i think that
the potential is there for the private
sector to get engaged at the grade level
but at this point it's still an effort
to develop the engineering to show how
best stacy forging the future report
there were there specific
recommendations in terms of what
government or anybody else ought to be
doing to realize the benefits yes excuse
me there were specific recommendations
again you have this huge supply but the
regional demand is really really low and
so the key question was how can you
build regional demand more regional
demand so that the region really
benefits from the economic potential so
one of the strategies was what Morgan
said yeah just getting more natural gas
into homes the second strategy was
around how to develop economic clusters
that where you can get let's say
advanced manufacturing data centers
users of a lot of natural gas that would
want low cost natural gas to come and
develop these economic clusters and that
plays right into this region strength
which is robotics innovation
manufacturing and so that was the second
strategy was around those clusters the
third strategy was actually around
advanced
infrastructure to export some of the gas
so there is so much gas here that
probably you could never use it here
even if you had a lot of data centers
and more crackers so getting some of
this gas to the Gulf Coast's which can
link it into global markets is actually
also important so Stacey oh I don't mean
to keep you on the spot here but I'm
gonna shift topics but keep you talking
Stacey and I are both participants at
something call the center responsible
shale development so the premise for
this for that Center which is a
collaboration between Chevron shall eqt
[Music]
console now CNX EDF Environmental
Defense Fund the Pennsylvania viral
council is that if shale gas development
is going to occur then it ought to be
done right that is with minimal
environmental impact in the center
through the collaboration among these
companies and environmental groups
created a set of standards based on
Heron and water impacts so Stacy the
question for you is so why would Chevron
participate in it it needs to be said
that there's standards created by this
Center or in every case at least as
stringent and in most cases more
stringent than the state standards in
any state in which Chevron was working
and true for the other companies also so
why why would you do that well first I
want to thank you
Jerry actually has served for five years
as that the board chair for this really
important organization and it's not
always been an easy job so it's been
nice to work with you since I got here
on that and we can declare a success I
think Jerry in that like you said that
we have raised the standard actually the
regulatory standard because it makes
sense for all of us to operate to the
highest economic and stand an
environmental standard it and y'all
touched on this as well right I mean
emissions accidents pollution is not
good for any of us and it's not good for
our industry and so I think you'll find
globally anywhere that Chevron operates
we're operating to the highest standard
that we can I I would just add the
premise for the center is belief that
companies need a quote social license to
operate that is they have to operate in
a way so that the society in which they
are operating believes that they are
doing the best they can can in their in
their production so Anna we're at that
point where we could allow for some
questions if maybe we have a little time
for that we have a couple of questions
so one of the questions that's come is
is what do you see as the R&D and
innovation needs for downstream natural
gaseous R&D deeds downstream everybody
wants you to answer that Dave sure I
have a good answer for it off the cuff
this is a very traditional industry in
general what word we're still three to
four years away from product from the
shell cracker
and once we get that and there's an
abundance of residents plastic residents
we do expect to see a lot more Rd in
terms of product development customer
engagement but it's I'm not in a
position to kind of predict which
direction that's going to go maybe
Michael could find a little more
I can add a little something here on so
that talked about the tri-state
coalition and a study they recently put
out they also put one out last year at
the same conference and that one
highlighted how Pennsylvania is is
really kind of well-positioned to take
the next step here because there's to a
college and university Penn State Erie
has the the Barron plastic school and
Penn College has a school that also
focuses specifically on plastics
engineering and frankly that was a kind
of a surprise good surprise learning for
shell and we'll definitely see some
opportunities to partner there with
those two institutions and what they're
they're faculty and students and and
draw up on their talents to look at
future R&D happenings at our facility
Morgan's gonna add the and again I don't
understand the subject matter but the
the McKenzie studies have recommended
that carbon fibers and future
petrochemical feedstocks would be
important for the manufacturing future
for the downstream because among other
things they can be made recyclable and
that drives the price down to make it
competitive carbon fibers are stronger
and lighter than other materials and
Mackenzie's reported at least to Ohio
and West Virginia to that they've done I
think this might be referred to in the
Pennsylvania report also is that this is
a clear opportunity for the region as to
the Rd part I think clearly this region
has strengths in in what Carnegie Mellon
is strong and that one doubts the world
leadership on that score who is really
good in the in the downstream
development of future products is a
little bit more spread out I know that
there's a German company that's looking
at it as a recycling facility for carbon
fibers in the UK that's looking to
create one here and they get their work
done and an oak ridge so I think maybe
that's something we need to actually put
some thought into that very issue who is
who are the sources for the Rd for the
the future product development yeah you
know and I think the attitude that we
took with Carnegie Mellon was to
basically have an open mind
listen and as we began that dialogue we
were introduced you know we basically
said you know any ideas and things that
people are working on that you think
would apply and make us better at what
we're doing knowing what our mission is
we'd love to be the sandbox that people
played in and and since that time you
know we now have I call them drones but
I don imus flying devices that actually
are basically flying along the bridges
in western Pennsylvania that we have
quite a few of and a lot of them have
gas lines underneath and typically
historically we would have folks
underneath those bridges checking those
pipes these drones now go flying through
the air and give us better better data
and it's obviously much safer we've also
been introduced to a robotics strategy
that literally threw gas lines as small
as four inches a robot can go through
and literally take photos of the inside
of the pipe to give us a real real-time
depiction of of what that looks like and
they also have the ability to seal
joints particularly in some of the older
bigger pipes and so and then the last
innovation that we we sort of been
introduced with our relationship here is
the idea of putting a fuel cell in
somebody's home combined with a battery
I know there's a lot of discussions
around battery where you basically take
the natural gas that you know we have
the capacity to deliver to your home and
literally convert it to electricity in
your house without any combustion and
then that that fuel cell which is a very
proven technology in big data centers
and other technology it's actually
making it economic on a smaller scale
that's been the challenge in that
industry we're through the partnership
that we have we're gonna be introducing
a hundred fuel cells over the next
twelve months into people's homes who
would be willing to see how this works
but so I think you know I think from on
our end of it we we've tried to be you
know an open door to let others come
and help us think this troops I think
that how we how we've done things in the
past is changing so quickly that nearly
everything that you know people talk
about in this region that Amazon is
excited about all these other things
traditional industries like mine can can
embrace and really partner with some of
these calm really smart young people and
I think it's we're just at the beginning
of it and I think it's gonna be
dramatically probably more quickly than
anything make us so much more
responsible and that fear that I started
with not only put that to ease but also
help you and people that we serve come
up with environmental answers that make
economic sense that take advantage of
this and as you say that those always
some environmental impacts but taking
those next steps I think there's a lot
of opportunities for traditional ways
changing and making it a much much
better path forward thank you Anna
time for one more we have a question is
the increasing share of natural gas for
power generation causing any shifts in
your priority for replacement and
upgrade of old infrastructure I think
that's for uh no it's I guess it's for
me I would say what's really you know we
we have changed our infrastructure
strategy almost completely around the
environmental impacts I would say that
nothing more has more impact on how we
were and how we would have done it
versus how we're doing it
what pipes were replacing those old
pipes with and the ability to
potentially serve more gas to our
customers and bring more gas in I think
is is probably an answer to that
question we are thinking of the future
of this region not the past how we used
it so we've got building capacity to
serve rural communities building
capacity to bring more generation online
that historically have been using coal
and nuclear but then also looking at all
the downstream opportunities to say
we're not replacing pipe for pipe
we're actually looking at what the
future of this region looks like and we
want infrastructure to be in place so
that as these opportunities come about
we can serve them else what I'm working
on that one well Anna noting that the
last panel ran over a little bit and bit
into our time how about one more
question you've caught me off guard here
well let me let me acknowledge that the
moderator of the last session was also
your boss so I guess that explains
celibate but what at mine that's right
so there's a couple of questions related
to pipelines okay and the export of this
fuel resource so are there any plans on
thinking about keeping that resource
here for both people and workforce and
productivity good stays to restate my
earlier comment around how large the
resource is the McKinsey study that we
worked on did not model that it was
possible to use all that gas here and so
it makes economic sense to export it out
of the region and if you can get it to
the Gulf Coast the gas can be liquefied
it can go on a barge and it can go to
any demand center anywhere in the world
and so you know I think it's better to
capture as most economic value as you
can in this region and that's what if
these strategies are successful but it's
actually you can't use all the gas here
it's so big is what the study found yeah
I think one of the statistics that we
saw and I use this
I'm talking to governor wolf or anybody
and Pat this is offense of the
regionalization that you've created but
if you just look at what's in
Pennsylvania of the Marcellus and Utica
and just in Pennsylvania it's enough to
power to provide the United States its
entire energy needs so if there were no
other energy sources other than this for
like the next 15 years and so there's a
lot of gas here and we're never gonna be
able to utilize all of it here and I
think that's the obvious and I would
just add from an economic development
standpoint I said we're particularly
interested in natural gas liquids our
job is to bring more crackers and more
propane facilities to the region to use
this NGLs the problem is it all comes
out of the ground together so if we want
the natural gas liquids to turn into
plastics to build manufacturing
facilities we need to bring the methane
out with it and we can't use it all here
so we're going to have to export at
least some of it so let me just close
this by saying reminding you where we
started we're sitting on top of the
largest shale gas reserve in the country
and one of the largest in the world if
we're going to use fossil fuels and many
people at this university are committed
to finding a way to reduce our
dependence on fossil fuels but if you're
gonna use them and you want to use them
wisely and do in a way that produces
maximum benefit I will tell you from my
perspective having interacted with all
the people on this panel and their
colleagues in in this industry and
environmental groups we're fortunate to
have the particular companies that we do
have exploiting this resource yes there
are viral impacts and they're creating
our admissions or discharges but as you
heard and I saw I've seen sort of behind
the scenes they were genuinely committed
to doing it with the smallest impact
that you know please join me in thanking
this panel
[Applause]
I guess yeah okay well then we'll just
come out
Hey
right now alright folks these mics hot
we're gonna get we're gonna go right
into it
how's everybody doing it's 2:30 yeah
feeling okay that's one person okay so
looking forward again this started my
name is Dan law I am NOT an energy guy
I'm actually a startup guy so I just
wanted to thank Carnegie Mellon and Ana
and the Scott Institute folks for
letting me be here and offering a couple
remarks about what we do around
innovation so we're not energy folks at
all in fact we're not trying to pick
winners we're what we call a start build
hub we're over in East Liberty and we're
called ascender and as a 501 C 3
non-profit we like to talk about things
like innovation ecosystems and high
growth vertical software-as-a-service
platforms and all that kind of stuff but
and we'd like to talk about energy too
but one thing that we've been noticing a
lot is that behind all of these terms
and buzzwords are a very human story in
all of our ecosystems and all of our
problems and all of our challenges are
really made up of individuals and human
beings and that's what we like to
celebrate and so you know without diving
too far into it I think the investment
component of these stories is really
really important and it really informs
in some respects the future of what
we're going to be as a region and
interestingly enough everybody on the
panel here none of you are from
Pittsburgh right one Bruce
Marty you went to CMU maybe so we're
bringing folks here from Vancouver
Chicago New York Berkeley I think
outside New York City that's pretty
exciting and that's pretty cool stuff so
without further ado Bruce you're gonna
be moderating today he is the partner
and pathfinder of Capital Advisors Eric
Burkhart
how are you the chief executive officer
of Clean Energy Trust won't lick my
fingers here Matt Myers vice president
of Earth X Marty which already called
you chief executive officer of a VOC
innovations Johanna Wolfson principal of
prime impact fund as I just strap myself
it's a millennial moment so first off
I'd like to thank everybody for being
here Bruce I'm gonna hand it over to you
and I'm looking forward to the
discussion on the investor's perspective
trends and insights and energy
innovation
okay there we go again on brewski of our
Pathfinder capital advisor for what it's
worth
Pittsburgh native recently come back and
got involved with various companies have
gone done a lot of energy work both as
placing investors as a broker dealer as
well as doing seed investment for some
local clean tech companies and other
things and I'm deeply appreciative of
the fact that that Anna and others
invited me and also concur with the rest
of my panel that we talked about earlier
we're glad to be here so what we'd like
to do is just have a informative
discussion as best we can as to where we
see the market perhaps you're an
entrepreneur looking it at how to fund
things what to do and we'd like to give
you some insights to that since I'm at
Carnegie Mellon I'll sort of make a
robotics comment that somebody had once
been quoted as saying that the jobs
likely to be automated or substitute it
with robotics or the three out of the
four DS dirty dull dangerous and
demeaning so therefore we will try not
to be any of those because we don't want
to be a substitute with with the robot
by by next year and so let me throw it
open to the panelists that in a world
where venture capitals are more easily
to fund an app that you know sort of
makes you look like a cap or something
else that we're some kind of social
network type of thing and clean tech
involves you know physical items areas
that are a little bit harder to do how
and why did you decide to participate in
the energy space start with Eric and
work our way down if that's okay it's
great to be here and I've actually my
first time on Carnegie Mellon's campus
and quite impressed I hope to come back
a bit later this year and spend a few
days here because there's definitely
just a wealth of assets here that I'd
like to learn more about but so you know
I became involved sort of in clean tech
in energy by beginning my career in
industrial products right at a time when
it became apparent that rather than sort
of trying to sell these products on
feeds and speeds that you could really
construct a pretty compelling financial
argument around energy savings so I got
pulled into clean tech in energy
efficiency and demand-side management
basically by you know figuring out a new
approach to selling products such as
pumps and lighting systems and so forth
but you know fast-forward today you know
what keeps me in it and what what the
reason I'm now doing what I'm doing is
you know previously my career I was
always working for you know trying to
make a single company successful and now
it might roll at cleaner to trust to
have the opportunity to really work and
try to make a whole sector successful
and help many different companies kind
of break through and succeed and that
and that's really what gets me going and
keeps me you know active and out of that
each morning so the question is how we
wound up in in investing in clean tech
so my pathway here was really from that
of a lab scientist trained as a physical
chemist in materials and I was really
passionate about solving energy
challenges in the lab and when I was in
graduate school at MIT I felt like I was
surrounded by incredible science and
really sci-fi stuff that could change
the world and the more I learned about
the path afterwards I realized there's
no pathway out or that the pathway out
is really broken and that's when I
started learning about all of the
mechanics around investing and
manufacturing and all of the really all
of the hard stuff that follows an
invention in the lab and learning about
how the by and large the startup support
system and financing system that we have
is optimized for capital light software
like technologies so I became really
passionate
about working on those challenges
specifically for Hardware intensive
technologies hello there we go so Marty
read my path shortly after graduating
Carnegie Mellon I moved out to Silicon
Valley and was a classic tech
entrepreneur did five startups and went
through kind of that personal decision
point in my life where I said enough
developing apps for free kitty-cats and
I really wanted to dedicate myself to
issues around climate change and when I
made the decision to switch over to
venture capital had the good fortune to
partner with a few folks in Berkeley who
are like-minded and so for that point on
really drove down the path of making
investments around that that sort of
climate thesis and now just recently I
guess now two years ago I made the
decision to move to Vancouver call me a
trump refugee I guess but we launched
evoke with a different focus which was
or a more specific focus I guess which
was instead of trying to transform the
energy sector from Berkeley and no
offense to Berkeley but I've now
partnered with some of the world's
largest oil and gas companies and I'm
helping them drive towards a zero carbon
future and so our model is now somewhat
akin to what what Dave was talking about
with breakthrough energy ventures in our
case just specific to that one thesis
around industrial processes so that's my
background
hi I'm Beth solder from cyclotron Road
my my foray into this area I think
started in in college I guess when I you
know at that time I feel like the
emphasis on achieving environmental
goals is really about regulation and at
as I went through grad school it started
to shift to to the idea that you can
make money while doing good things for
the environment
and it and I realized that the
misalignment between the or should I say
the the fact that the people working on
the science weren't necessarily always
really wherever well-versed in what the
economics of what they were doing and
the impacts that they were having made
me start looking actually very closely
in graduate school at looking at the
intersection of science and economics
and in particular looking at technical
economic models of how new technologies
and emerging technologies might perform
in the marketplace and in particular I
was very interested in bioenergy energy
crops at that at that time or starting
to become involved there's a lot of
research being done on that and the
question I had was well if we have this
resource what's the most cost effective
way to use it to to mitigate carbon
emissions there's multiple technologies
right you have biofuels you can have
gasification combined cycle you can have
Co fire with coal
well which one of those makes the most
sense and you can't do that it basically
what it came down to was what's the the
cheapest way to avoid a ton of carbon
right with this resource and so I really
got into doing to looking at some of
NREL techno-economic models and
realizing that this was really important
that people who are working on the
technology really need to understand at
a fundamental level the key drivers of
what's going to make something
competitive or not especially as a
commodity from there I then went to work
at a biofuels company put your money
where your mouth is um and did directed
an R&D program there on trying to reduce
the cost of actually macro algae or
seaweeds a feedstock I know a lot about
seaweed and then finally and now I'm
working at a cyclotron Tureaud which is
a
a program hosted at Lawrence Berkeley
National Lab were funded by advanced
manufacturing office of the midea we on
the California Energy Commission and
also DARPA to help early-stage
innovators but advanced their
technologies from lab to market and one
of the things I focus on there is
helping people in developing a
curriculum around how to teach
scientists and engineers coming out of
those programs to understand the
fundamental economics of their their
technologies and the markets and so
building you know we listened earlier
today breakthrough energy ventures even
the battery forum you hear talking about
techno economic modeling and so that's I
think a really important connection
between
the science that our people are doing
the lab and the investors that want to
invest in their technologies but need to
understand what needs to happen to make
that to make that work so I'm excited to
be in that in that space and continuing
to work there hey I got oh I'm alive
Matt Myers Earth X my path is a has been
a winding one I would say that I was
first inspired because I lived in China
for six and a half years was doing my
graduate degree out there at chin-hua
University doing my MPA and
International Development and with
studying climate change and our
professor brought in one of the top
negotiators for for China and he showed
the demand for for steel and cement from
2012 to 2020 and it just kept
skyrocketing and they said oh yeah it's
gonna it's gonna peak around 2020 and
then it'll level out and start declining
gradually and I as you all most people
in this room who I know those are the
true the most energy intensive
industries out there and I looked out
the window and I could barely see a tree
that was eight feet ten feet away from
me because the amount of
solution in the air I actually couldn't
eat locally for the last year and a half
that I that I lived there I was eating
canned peaches and imported beef from
Australia and yogurt from Germany
because my gastrointestinal system
couldn't take it anymore and so for me
it was physically experiencing what
what's happening with the environment
the impact it was having on society and
the impact it was happening on myself
and then also looking at the data and
thinking oh geez we are we're screwed if
we don't do a couple things one have
policy that puts a price on carbon and
negative externalities which is probably
not going to happen United States and
the other would be deploying a huge
amount of capital towards solutions that
are going to save the planet I didn't
get a chance to work on that for a
little while as pads are winding met our
founder Earth X founder trammel escrow
philanthropist environmentalists are
green Republican in 2009 in Shanghai
moved back long story told short founded
a clean tech Investment Summit called a
capital summit now it's almost two years
and from a blank screen to what it is
now and at the core of it we are working
to get conservative Texans to take a
look at the space especially high net
worth individuals and families and
hopefully start deploying in that area
let me tell you it is a it's a tough job
but from what I learned this the
Appalachian region has a similar
political culture and makeup and I'm
delighted to say that I feel now after
two years that we are starting to make
progress
because people are understanding that
that cleantech is really increasing
efficiency across many different
industries and there is a economic case
to be had so that is my my story I guess
okay thank you I appreciate everyone's
thoughts on that it's just an
interesting note how in each case you
know your personal observations and what
you had affect you you know really does
have an impact as to what you do for the
rest of your life just real quickly on
my side I'm probably a little older than
the average panelist here remember as a
kid sort of state you know being in a
line during the oil embargo you know
trying to get gasoline and I read a
couple books of energy future and limits
to growth and a couple other different
things and back then people thought
there was sort of an ironclad
relationship between GDP and energy use
I mean you could read it in books again
it again it made no sense to me so when
I became an engineer and I started
looking at it I said there's so much
inefficiency in every one in every
system and it still continues to this
day it's amazing and the other thing
that always fascinated me about energy
is the tentacles are everywhere I mean
it affects literally we would not be
able to talk to you on microphones we
would be a dark room there's
socio-political economic you name it
it's affected really energy is kind of
the Nexus of life so to speak you you
can't get around it through it or
whatever and it certainly does make life
an awful lot easier for those people
that have it so let me move on to the
next question or I mean all of you could
be regarded as as being involved in sort
of social impact investing ie getting
something more than just your dollar
affecting society with your investment
and some people would call it the Golden
Age of impact investing is that the
Golden Age is it going to last or is
the fan run with it go ahead I'll leap
in just quickly I think the phrase
Golden Age may be a little bit
aggressive because I think we're really
only at the front end you know if you
just consider the trillions of dollars
of through the capital markets I mean
they're so it's it's almost a rounding
error in terms of the type of you know
investment that's going into you know
the impact category so I think it's just
at the very very front end and you know
Prime Coalition is doing great work
trying to figure out how to get
foundations you know into the
marketplace you know Matt describes
trying to get high net worth individuals
in the marketplace I mean we're only
we're only at the very very very
beginning first steps so yeah I would
agree with that I don't think it's a fad
I think it's a trend that is that it
will continue to grow I think it's very
it's a very imprecise term so I always
when I get asked about impact investing
I always try to understand what someone
means by that and there can be there are
there are shades of what that means and
I think some of those shades are
represented on this panel which is great
so sometimes that can mean profit
seeking capital seeking impact alongside
it so there's there's absolutely no
concession in terms of what's being
sought sometimes there is what's called
concessionary capital that's looking to
take that that's all right with taking
some some lower return or accepting
similar return or taking higher risk
with some trade-off for impact where
prime is on that is we are unabashedly
impact first but we're only able to do
that because we're using charitable
philanthropic capital and we it probably
would not be appropriate for most
venture funds to take that approach so I
think there's a whole continuum and it's
useful to describe it because I think
that as we see that trend evolve it'll
kind of move
if from one end which is more kind of
double bottom line focus yes we're in it
for impact but we're also in it we're
not surrendering any returns I think
that's where we're seeing the trend
start and it will I think continue to
evolve along that spectrum is my guess
I'll jump in and my my perspective on
this having been through a cycle or so
2007 was the Golden Age of course we
were completely clueless and lost all of
our money so be careful what you wish
for and so from that peak in oh seven
through now we're still down 90 plus
percent and cleantech as a percentage of
venture capital which is you know my
particular focus within the capital
stack still is only about two percent of
the overall capital going in but I do
however have reason for optimism in in
there is now been an emergence of some
some new models obviously we talked
about breakthrough energy ventures og CI
is an example in the energy sector which
is a consortium roughly ten you know
global energy companies who have put in
a billion dollars you know to my voke
you know I think what we created evoke
is an interesting approach where we take
some some of the attributes of
traditional financial venture
investments with strategic investing and
now you're also starting to see some
models that are supporting those
companies that we screwed up in 2007 and
the physical sciences through smarter
incubator programs like cyclotron Road
which I love and we've invested in
several cyclotron Road companies and if
you're in the physical sciences space
and trying to commercialize I can't
recommend a program higher and I hope
they replicate this I know they're
starting to replicate at National Labs
but I hope that universities are
starting to look at that also I think
it's a fantastic model
so so I'll just add to that I think that
one of the issues with with impact
investing is how do you have a sort of
an objective quantifiable screen for
what that impact is and it's very
difficult if you're an investor to all
of a sudden understand but how you can
condense all the nuance metrics that
could go into something like impact
which as a word is Serena pointed out is
incredibly vague and can can capture a
lot of different things I think one of
the things that that cyclotron Road does
is it is it provides a very highly
vetted filter AM screen for for
technical merit and not just technical
merit but also we screen fourth sort of
the personality characteristics that we
look for in our innovators that we think
will lead to successful outcomes yeah I
think that's a important point and I
know prime actually has written a paper
on this but the the question you know
the impact in how you define it and how
you measure it is basically nobody's
cracked the code on that there's not a
consistent framework there's not a
consistent methodology being pursued and
part of the issue is if you look at a
framework
yeah that's used let's say at a fortune
500 company like iris right that's a
retroactive look that's basically
telling you what's happened but you know
we're all dealing with technologies that
are coming out of the lab they're
nowhere near scale they're not near the
market or maybe they're just entering
the market you really to measure what
their potential impact will be kind of
on a forward-looking basis is incredibly
difficult in the danger I think is that
there'll be a propagation of different
approaches and methodologies and
suddenly people will get concerned
because they don't know who to trust and
it may actually scare capital away from
the space particularly those people who
are approaching
with an impact lens yeah I I agree and I
mean I do a lot of work in a
conservative part of the country and
I've had to shift and its ROI first
impact second now impact what does that
mean yeah you want to have a positive
impact on society on the planet who
doesn't but at the end of the day it's
it's also about ROI people want to make
a return on their investment and I thing
that I'm talking about now with some
folks is that everybody is admitting
that the climate is changing
they just can't say climate change even
Scott Pruett is saying but the climate
is changing okay we all we all know it
it's baked in the data is there so why
aren't we moving faster and I think this
is the biggest arbitrage in human
history for for what's gonna take place
over the coming years because if we
don't change the planet's gonna force
governments to change and that's gonna
lead to a huge amount of capital flow
deal flow towards these industries so
for me that's the way I've I've started
to paint it especially the past months
let me kind of add the Wall Street
perspective right so again we we have a
broker-dealer so not only we've done
seed investment but we also have talked
with fairly large substantial and not
every one of the problems I find is some
of these people frankly are not as
educated shall we say in the
technologies or understanding it or even
assessing the probability of success and
so you've got different slices and you
don't all have everyone doesn't have a
danielson frankly that that that they
can have is somebody to say hey here's
the big picture this is what's going on
and here's a long term here's a ten-year
horizon
there's a lot of money that's just like
okay I need to get an extra turn in my
fund I need to get it now and unless it
really is allocated towards something
that is clean tech or says look I want
something more than just a return so let
me kind of toss out another question
which is can you get a decent return in
the clean tech environment is is
investing its own virtue in this sector
I'm gonna jump in because I kind of have
to I want to comment a bit about sort of
this whole sustainability label on in
those of you that we're in the room
yesterday got a view of you know how
Blackstone looks at sustainability which
is they don't use that word they're
simply driving for efficiency an ROI I
get pretty nervous as we talk about
standardizing reporting for
sustainability and impact because I just
I think it drives strange behaviors
anytime accountants are driving business
decisions it's a bad day no offense to
the accountants in the room Oh same
comment as it relates to lawyers for
what it's worth in it and so I'll give
one real example and so we've made an
investment in a machine learning
artificial intelligence company that by
most metrics no one would look at and
say oh that is an amazing sustainability
bet or an investment and yet when we
deployed it in a brownfield natural gas
application so across you know several
hundred wells
we drove both the 20% increase in
efficiency and basically output of the
of the field but with a seventy four
percent reduction in methane emissions
that will trump anything that we are
towing in the sort of you know
sustainability feel-good space out there
a 74 percent reduction in three months
using artificial intelligence and so
that's the sort of investment where we
are expecting very much a you know a
sizable venture return I will comment
though when you start looking at some of
these longer lived sort of hard tech to
use that term this sort of deals that
that Damon was talking about where it
may take 18 years well if you apply at
this
cash flow 225 you know a discount or a
25% discount right well you better have
a you better be solving a massive
massive problem if that's if that's what
you're going after so you can do it but
you can't do it in the same way we did
it in 2012
the way we tried to do it in 2007 and
fail so I just I just want to jump in a
little bit just to clarify my point on
impact so let's say you have three funds
that are out in the market raising money
right they could put forward their track
record from a financial return
perspective but increasingly these funds
are going out there and also putting
forth metrics around impact you know
greenhouse gas emissions reduce jobs
created economic development you know a
variety of different metrics the
challenge is that right now there's no
objective way of assessing whether what
they're putting out there is true or not
so slowly you have three funds out there
approaching a limited partner at some
point the limited partners gonna say you
know I can't assess what's true and
what's not and they're gonna step back
right and that's the danger I think of
pulling in some of the people off the
sidelines who might not be playing in
the space so well and I'll add to that
because I've seen situations where again
being a being a Carnegie Mellon kid I
was taught to sort of dig into the data
and just not look at the headline if you
dig into the data on some of these bold
claims and you're sort of like wait a
minute timeout somebody once told me
that that stress can be defined as the
difference between expectations and
reality and sometimes to get money
people give artificially high
expectations and then if they don't
deliver obviously investors are gonna
get stressed out and there's a real
danger because once you lose your back
and you're the Neanderthal back in the
cave going I'm not going to go out there
I might get crushed again so you know
it's an interesting time but I think
it's got to be played correct
it's got to have good solid investments
and people that are actually making
prudent decisions so I'll add to that I
totally agree with the point that Marty
made and I think it's I think it's an
important one that's not talked about
much that some of these longer term time
horizon funds it if there's an
expectation for venture like returns
even up over a long time frame that's
still really hard to hit on an IRR basis
but I think it's important to to the to
the root of your question you know can
there be money you made or is virtue its
own reward I don't think it is its own
root word I don't think impact
personally I don't think impact can be
achieved unless big new companies are
built that achieve commercial success
so I think ultimately the only viable
pathways are one that are commercially
attractive to to commercial capital
where where we don't look for a return
for our capital when we place
philanthropic capital into companies but
we would never do it if we didn't think
that there was rent seeking capital
venture style capital ready and waiting
to take it over from us so that's kind
of how we try to square that circle okay
we're but a little bit halfway through
the session we want to leave a little
bit for for QA toward the end so I don't
want to me to be political but just
factual the recent change in
administration's in Washington how has
that changed your perspective on
investing in some of these sectors okay
we'll move on I'll jump in I moved to
Canada because I had concerns with US
political system I believe one top of
that Vancouver has a spectacular place
to live
you know I I think we all just about
jumped off well I'll speak for myself i
I almost jumped off a cliff two years
ago or whatever it was for fear that the
world was going to end and when we all
step back you know a day later the
president actually does not have as much
power as any of us made made here and we
were my camp quite pleasantly surprised
with you know
additional funding for RP and the like
and so I think our worst expectations
are proving to not be the case and you
know life goes on I will say though and
I will waive the Canadian flag living in
a country where we believe in science
we've put a price on carbon and we are
moving towards improved policy is
refreshing and in for the first time I'm
seeing a pretty significant migration of
talent north as opposed to just a
migration of talent into Silicon Valley
and that's whoever has that brain the
advantage on the intellect will win in
the long term and if US doesn't solve
some of this immigration I'm more
concerned about immigration than I am
about our climate policy right now if we
chase away talent we are in trouble as
you can speak in the United States and
what is Canada in the last six months
every day that the US tightens its
immigration canada open sis and that's
what i'm most fearful Thank You anyone
else anyway with the Canada I think I
think we should just all look at deep
politicizing the word cleantech and
let's look at the economics of it and
what it means for the United States to
be a leader in these industries for the
betterment of everybody period okay this
November vote for them I'll add one or
two things that my perspective is a
little bit different and because one of
the things dealing with with tax credits
which are the currency and solar and
wind and some other different things
right unique clarification from the IRS
because while one side of the government
says you could do this they passed the
law then the IRS survey it says no no
you have to do it this way that way that
way and you got to stand on your head
and something else
making that out but but they need
compliance with existing you know
Treasury regulations so when I heard for
example well for every regulation that
we put in place we're going to take two
away well there's these things called
Reb procs and guidance and things like
that that the IRS has to give that
creates certainty for the industry to
make sure that they're doing things that
they know they're going to get the
credit and unfortunately and again I'm
not quite sure who why because I think
both sides blame each other there's some
positions particularly within IRS that
that are unfilled since the last
administration well if the traffic cop
isn't there to tell you whether you can
go and the lights out it kind of makes
it a little bit difficult to figure out
whether you can kind of make a
right-hand turn go straight or anything
else so I'll add that is my perspective
it's a little bit different I think but
but aside from that I think the societal
issues are still there
and people were pushing and you could
still make a decent dollar from these
kind of investments what about Berkeley
how do people feel in Berkeley oh boy
it's working I'm an employee at Berkeley
Lab so indirectly report to Rick Perry
but actually he visited the lab just
last week actually and unless he was
really putting on an act he was really
impressed with what we were doing there
and actually there's a great video of
him having a tug of war with one of our
one of our founders ray y de Kamp who's
developing a ultra strong 3d printable
resin he made a wishbone and there's a
cool video of them both trying to break
the wishbone who won the competition I
think Rick Perry did and that was
probably I'm not sure but I
that was engineers so let's let's kind
of move on and the reason why sort of
ask this question is to get insight as
to you know what you've learned over
time what was your favorite energy
investment as well as one you thought
would be world-class but ended up not so
much
describe what you learned I'll take a
crack at it
I'll let's track the question a little
bit if that's okay absolutely yes one
learning experience for me has been I I
get really interested in the technology
and the cost perspective and the the
business model and all that and taking
on taking on the impact lens which for
us is about greenhouse gas emissions
just realizing how much how many new
developments out there are potentially
very impactful or
sorry are potentially innovative and
could could make a good business but
might not move the needle in a big way
on greenhouse gas emissions and so one
of the things that we've developed
internally that Eric alluded to is a is
an internal way to to project out
forward-looking greenhouse gas emissions
and I've just I've learned that some of
the technologies that I get excited
about and think that they could be
really good businesses like say a
battery better battery separator
membrane or something like that really
compelling from a business perspective
actually doesn't have necessarily the
climate impact that we might be looking
for so that's a lens that I'm
increasingly seeing filter things out
for us I'll jump in I will say this goes
back to 2007 but we were the largest
shareholder in a company called Solazyme
which was one of the early biofuels
bio-oil splays in you know we thought it
was going to be fantastic we went public
a billion dollar valuation and today it
doesn't exist and it doesn't exist
because of the shale revolution
frankly and I I think that is a trend
not to take lightly obviously and when
you think about long-term price on
natural gas the other to think about is
when electrification of light vehicles
takes over and demand for oil drops now
you're gonna see oil become super cheap
so if you're a biofuels play trying to
compete with super cheap natural gas
super cheap oil good luck
and so it's just a space that I know a
lot of people talk about and are excited
by I'm scared to death of it and I don't
know what it would take to convince me
to get back in on the flip side what am
I really excited about I mentioned you
know this this investment we made an AI
company I think there are unbelievable
opportunities for AI in industrial
applications that will have a massive
impact in terms of efficiency and
emissions in that space the other one
I'm really excited about we've made an
investment in this is synthetic biology
applications with new gene editing tools
within synthetic biology are amazing and
we're now pointing those towards various
industrial applications
I think there's a lot of promise there
Eric yeah so I think a company that
we're excited about but also just really
proud of the founding team it's a
company called new mat technologies
material sciences material science IP
out of Northwestern but the company came
together in response to a Department of
Energy student business plan competition
they came together they won the
competition it gave them a little bit of
a win in their sales to take this IP and
try to build a company around it and for
a number of years they just cast about
and frankly they were they were
struggling because they couldn't find
you know the right beachhead market or
the right sort of application for this
you know metal organic frameworks
technology that they had developed and
then just through sheer perseverance
they finally zeroed in on an application
and sort of noxious and industrial gases
to help storage of those gases that
basically you're
you know room pressure to you know
eliminate the need for compression and
so forth and also in the market just you
know opened up for them and they've been
just doing great they're now raising
their Series B I think their valuation
you know is you know up forty million
dollars you know a few years ago they
were you know students coming out
Northwestern University so just really
proud of it but I think the lesson there
is the that are really identifying that
that that highly focused target market
to go after initially to sort get your
company on a good growth trajectory in
terms of just a company I'm sort of I
feel for is a company that has an IOT
platform for compressed air and
pneumatic systems for industrial
applications great technology that you
know what they've bumped up against and
what they're bumping up against it's
just how difficult it is to sell into
you know an industrial facility if your
product touches a production process
because you know the you know the plant
manager you know they don't want
anything disrupting their production
flows and they're not gonna take a new
piece of technology and let it touch you
know a mission-critical production line
and great technology they just haven't
been able to break through on the sales
side and I just I just feel for them
because you know great team great
technology but yeah just a really tough
market or a real tough sales cycle can I
go off script for one second no sort of
counsel for anyone any entrepreneurs in
the room I know no new Matt fairly well
and I think it's an incredible example
of you know moths are not sort of
household you know terms that everyone
knows there was an incredible technical
depth behind the company but in my
opinion where it really came to shine is
they've got a CEO that is amazing and
he's amazing at doing customer discovery
and for those of you that are trying to
build a company sitting in a lab you
don't learn anything sitting in the lab
do you only learn stuff by getting in
front of potential customers and Ben has
been in I mean he is out there and when
I sat down first time he's like I talked
to one hundred and this vertical I
talked to under customer this well
here's my learnings here's and I was
like
just blown away and so you you do not
have a company until you've talked to a
hundred customers and really really know
the pain point that you're going after a
great example with you man like I got to
give my quick example I appreciate that
actually it's gonna lead into the next
question on what advice you'd give an
entrepreneur but I'll give a shout out
to a company that won last year's you
know clean University prized the which
was robot me and it was like when you
see something that you say wow this
makes perfect sense an indoor vertical
farming as as Dave Danielson talked
about we're gonna have food issues we
have you know water issues we have
fertilizer runoff with a wide variety of
different things and again they use LED
lights it's 40 feet high they're
building they just finished their series
a in the fall for 12 million dollars and
on the south side they're gonna be
making you know produce that's now
selling in Whole Foods but they're gonna
up that their production dramatically
they buy wind power for the LEDs and
they use robotics to keep the cost down
and to make it hyper efficient so when
it's ten degrees below zero outside in
Pittsburgh and January let's say they're
still gonna be just producing fresh
produce it also helps in the waste
because it's gonna be stead of trucking
it from the Salinas Valley several weeks
it actually shows up and a couple hours
later it's it's on the supermarket shelf
so it last longer so food waste and
creating things on one end of the
country shipping them to the point where
it only turns brown and no one buys it
doesn't make an awful lot of sense the
other thing I'll add is on the other
side of what doesn't work if there's
anything and particularly the larger the
capex the more consistent that margins
have to be over time I mean I've done
two I did design work on the Great
Plains coal gasification project in the
90s when we're recording with the Saudi
Arabia of coal how'd that work out
wasn't my investment but
sort of saw it that's consistent
throughout with energy and how you get
savings so but with that said let me
move on to our final question before we
turn it over to to everyone what advice
would you give to a scientist / or
entrepreneur in the audience who wanted
to start a company I was gonna say
cyclotron here I'd say keep your eyes
wide open be your own it's hard because
you have to be extremely optimistic but
extremely critical at the same time one
of the reasons why I really encourage
people to build their own technical
model is because you just need a
spreadsheet mix out and a few numbers
but because if you are the one if you're
the if you're the the technical person
you have much better insight into what
the potential of that technology is but
then building that spreadsheet model
allows you to then connect what you're
working on in the lab with whether or
not it actually moves the needle in the
marketplace and a lot of times that
they're totally disconnected a lot of
times the things that scientists want to
work on the sexy material or technology
has nothing to do with the actual cost
of the product or the facility it's it's
something more mundane like pH or the
type of metal you're going to use in the
in the processing plant that you need to
build right so I really very said talk
to people doing customer discovery it's
often uncomfortable for people
particularly were people who are you
know more comfortable working in the lab
to go out and talk to people but you'll
learn a lot but it's by talking to one
person and information that you'll never
be able to Google right or be able to to
capture in the lab anyone else just just
want to echo this get out of the lab get
uncomfortable I'm actually sitting in on
best techno economics course and working
really closely with one of the team's
that's going through it
and I see directly this this tension
between wanting to be precise and
correct and that how that prevents
technical founders in particular from
just guessing and have someone say no
that's wrong and this is the answer
that's what you want you want to get to
that point but you can't get to that
point until you get out of your comfort
zone so Eric you know I think Marty
called it out the customer discovery is
key one one piece of advice that you
know I just it just always dumbfound me
that I even have to articulate this but
we see it too often is just be honest be
truthful because it is just I'm always
just surprised at how often you know
particularly young entrepreneurs will
step over the line will not necessarily
come forward with the full truth about
their product their technology their you
know their success in the marketplace
the truth you know it's a small
community
people talk it's amazing how you know
you know the truth we'll find find find
a light and just you look garner more
respect and gain more ground with
investors if you are aboveboard honest
and transparent about your business so I
know it sorry I have to even say that
yeah no I I think that's absolutely
correct
I'll be quick just one as other addition
would be find a partner and so
particularly if you're a technical
founder find someone with that business
acumen that that can really strengthen
your weaknesses and if you want to see
what I think is the best example of it
opus 12 is a company we invested in two
brilliant technical founders who were
smart enough to then partner up with ex
McKinsey Stanford Business School grad
and then the three of them went out and
they're now just crushing it but the two
technical founders on their own would
have
where they are today without partnering
with that that business acumen so the
friend of mine actually uses the example
of wildebeest and and zebras and you
might look at me like what the heck you
talking about the Willoughby's can smell
very well but it can't see the zebra is
the opposite so the will to be smells
the lion and you'll always see them in
in lines together look at any picture
and the one identifies the Lions in the
area the other one goes where where okay
there it is in that sense when you have
a partnership right and same thing we
have great technical people maybe yes or
no as to the great business acumen often
not found in the same person but you
need somebody you can trust collaborate
with and bring your idea for it today
can I add two cents to and just say that
from my own experience as well that
entrepreneurship is not sexy at all oh
come on it's not it's really not it's a
it's a it's a total grind and it's a
roller coaster one minute you're up the
next to your way down so you could add
our love what you doing you got a whop
doing it it's not about the money it's
and I'll give a final piece advice
whatever we know whatever the subject
matter is particularly technically
people love to show how much they know
and and talk about which electrons
moving where and whatever okay I'm kind
of of the out alan alda school where he
said well you know describe what fire is
to a you know twelve-year-old
don't drag the people into the weeds
unless they say show me or talk to me
that the technology in detail investors
want to know at a high level this makes
sense there's advantages to it
there's economics to it there's no
competitor right now and then the
delve in and they'll hire somebody
probably to do the expertise to delve
into the technology but it never ceases
to amaze me how somebody wants to drag
me into the weeds and I don't want to go
[Music]
got one or two minutes here one of the
exciting new Texas tech areas you're
seeing and investing in today this could
be the last and final question I I'm not
gonna say blockchain so
if you if you say blockchain your your
value just went up four times but I
agree with you going well deal I'm
working on right now as an energy
storage with exactly the thesis Davis
was talking about earlier on long strong
steel so plus eight hour 12 hour energy
storage and she knows a bit about the
dough so yeah low cost storage and also
I think Dave Dave did a great job this
morning laying out some of the most
important areas and we are we are as I
said before German by greenhouse gas
emissions reduction potential so we
don't have a sector okay
yeah sector focus or anything like that
but that's that's one area we're looking
very deeply and carefully at carbon
capture as well as we're interested in
where we can have a role in funding
nuclear technologies as well and where
it's appropriate for philanthropic
capital to to fund something at a small
scale or if there's a if there's a
thesis there for us just to name a few
areas if somebody is looking for four
seed or pre seed funding what's the best
way to go about getting it or who to
talk to
that just came up as a question I'd say
apply to a cyclotron Road will provide
you runway seed funding access to to a
lab and time to figure out what your
product and market is before you
essentially get married to an investor
who might have different expectations
okay the wine forms right over here at
the reason - yeah I think applying to an
incubator or accelerator program
specifically that has a focus in this
area whether it be clean energy trust or
cyclotron Road or one of the other many
organizations that do a great job of
this
I think but but what you I think we want
to look for is a program team that has
deep knowledge in this area and has
hopefully some scars in this area
so they can again direct direct you
along the way for to avoid some of the
mistakes that happened the first time
around I have a personal goal at prime -
to see how long I can go before I tell a
company you're too early for us it
hasn't happened yet so we're willing to
go pretty early but we don't have a huge
pile of funding to send out so I would
love to say that a lot of we're hoping
to get to a place where there are a lot
of philanthropists who are willing to
support incredibly early seed stage
companies we're not quite there yet
we're working on it but I'm hopeful that
that's an area in the future that can
see it a lot more companies just grant
funding you know SBIRS RPE I mean work
every grant possibility for non diluted
funding I'll answer this one just
because they think this it may be
somebody else knows differently or to
incentivize investing is there lobbying
being done to make capital gains on a
clean tech investment tax exempt we just
went through the major you know tax
overhaul it actually made it more
difficult for things with tax credits
because people particularly corporates
are now taxed at 21 percent versus 35
and I don't see any new tax legislation
that's going to change anything and you
got to get both sides together to agree
and that's difficult in Washington so I
think we've reached our time limit Anna
is that correct she's given me the
thumbs up I don't know what that means
continue or you're done I think it means
you're done we're all going to thank and
who we have dubbed as a group the anti
entropy for those scientists in the room
ie she is one of the most organized
people that you ever want to be and we
think we think there may be you to give
her a round of applause thank you so
much for inviting us this is what I say
no no what I want to do though is thank
our panelists today I really appreciate
you being here and the insights you've
given us I know that you also had a lot
of meetings this morning and we hope
that those meetings were also fruitful
so thank you very much for being with us
on campus we have actually reached the
time for our afternoon break we are in
rain goes one and two in rangos three
which is directly behind that wall there
is a snack so we are going to take a
break please use the facilities which
are across the hall if you need a quiet
place for a phone call please let me
know but otherwise we will convene back
here at four o'clock sharp thank you
again to our panel
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway yeah so the